[Musique]
allez venez miller vous asseoir ma Table
J'ai fait oui
froid ici c'est confortable et c'est
vous faites milor et prenez bien vos aes
vos pipis Sur mon cur et vous p Sur une
chaise Je vous connais milor vous ne
j'ai
jamais Vu Je Ne suis qu'une fille du p
un nom du
[Musique]
rue pourtant Je vous Ai fré quand vous
passie
[Musique]
hier IL y a un mois pour quelques heures
ces affiches de tournée vont ere le
Signal d'un drame dont on tremble tout
Apprenez instantanément le dénouement
drame des dit
piaf avz le
je l'aurais dit
roi vous marchez hier ce soir diep
Demain veste soir après des semaines
cinéma en cinéma et piaf chante comme on
tente un Paris avec dieu Belle commentaire
on joue à la roulette russe j'en FR dans
toi
cur allez
venez vous avez l'air
laissez-vous faire milor venez dans mon
royaume Je soigne les remords Je chante
la romance Je chante les milor qui n'ont
pas eu de chance regarde-moi milor vous
Plus jamais
Vu mais vous
pleurésie
Milor je l'aurais jamais
cru
et Ben
voyez souriez mooi
mille mieux
quel petit
effort voil c'est allez rier Milo allez
chanteur
milo
[Musique]
Bravo
T
[Musique]